- We now need to let
these young people know
that they have been duped.
You know, we have kind
of let our guard down,
and just to kind of segue from that,
well, we let our guard down
to the probably the most
important place we can think about,
that's on the educational system.
As we've been kind of moving
on and having our big dreams
and, you know, being the eternal optimists
that we are as a country,
building our future,
our kids, and vacation,
we have not understood that
evil has been at our doorstep
every single step of the way.
They have gotten into our
educational system for decades,
and they have eaten away
like little termites
on the most important
thing that we can have
to keep our future, and
knowledge of our past,
what we've done together,
and most importantly,
what makes our country work,
the free market.
We have kids coming out of
college hating our country
because of our Marxist's laboratories
that've been putting together
for the last few decades.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and this is the Rubin Report.
Reminder, everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and
click that pesky notification bell.
So that you're alerted
when our new videos drop,
and joining me today is a former NFL star
and super bowl champion,
now running for Congress
in Utah's fourth district,
Burgess Owens.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
- Dave, thanks so much.
Looking forward to our chat, for sure.
- I'm glad to have you, man
because you are blowing up
(Burgess laughing)
every time I turn on television now.
I just did the Greg Gutfeld show
with you a couple of days ago,
but every time I see
somebody talking on Twitter,
a video of somebody doing something,
you seem to be right in
the middle of things.
You're enjoying this little
Congressional adventure?
- I really am
because, you know, we're
having a conversation
that's been long overdue, Dave,
but, you know,
we've been talking at hypothetically,
what can happen with socialism, Marxism?
And this is a conversation
we can have for years
and really not get through.
We have an opportunity
right now to let people know
this is the way it looks when
you give left power. (laughs)
They have no clue what to do
with it other than to abuse it.
So I think this is...
Well, obviously it's tough times,
but what I've come to
understand about America,
and I know my history,
when we go through the toughest of times,
and as long as we know
what the end game is,
what it takes to win,
we come together,
we put aside our differences
for a little bit of time
then we go out there
and make things happen.
So I see this as a great
opportunity to talk with
our democratic (mumbles) of our country,
to our black business owners, for sure,
they definitely get it,
and then those who have in the
past not been really engaged.
We are literally fighting
for the heart and soul of our
nation, and those guys on the other side
are totally...
They've gone nuts because they
realize how close they are
to losing it all,
so they are all hands on-board,
and just know that this is
gonna be, probably, the most
important few months we have
coming up in front of us now,
we just need to make sure
we take advantage of it.
And as Al Davis used
to say in the old days,
"Just win baby, we're
ready to get that done.
"Just win baby."
(laughs gently)
- So that's actually partly why I wanted
to have you on because of
your history as an athlete,
as an NFL player,
and even the way you
answered that question,
there's always a certain rhythm,
which I've always loved
the way so many athletes
speak about things,
and obviously you have some of that,
and I think we sort of
need a little bit more
of that right now.
People who know how to
win, not win at all cost,
but win within a certain
framework of rules and respect
for each other and
respect for the country,
and I really sense that out of you.
- And I'll tell you
what I'm excited about.
I've been hearing from a lot of my peers,
college peers and NFL peers.
You know, we came through a
time when it's quite different.
We came through a time where our parents
did such a great job,
and this is the thing that
I think is being lost.
We have had this last generation,
the great generation was truly remarkable.
They succeeded in so many different ways,
and to say that they were
helpless and hopeless,
and oppressed is a putdown
to them in a big big way.
But what I've been getting
is calls from the guys that I
came through with through college and pro,
and they're all on board.
We'd love the fact that we're
now talking about standing
for our flag, standing
for our country, respect,
which we were taught by our parents to do,
and we now need to let
these young people know that
they have been duped.
You know, we have kind
of let our guard down,
and just to kind of segue for that,
when we let our guard
down to what is probably
the most important place
we can think about,
and so the educational system.
As we've been kind of moving
on and having our big dreams
and, you know, being the eternal optimist
that we are as a country,
building our future,
our kids and vacation,
we have not understood that
evil has been at our doorstep
every single step of the way.
They've gotten into our
educational system for decades,
and they have eaten away like
little termites on the most
important thing that we can
have to keep our future,
and knowledge of our past,
what we've done together,
and most importantly,
what makes our country work,
the free market.
We have kids coming out of
college hating our country
because of the Marxist's laboratories
that we've been putting together
for the last few decades.
So this is a good time for us
even to start addressing that issue,
and one of the things I cannot wait to do
when I get to Congress.
By the way, let me just give you guys
a little quick advertisement
Burgessforutah.com.
(Burgess laughs)
Burgessforutah.com go there, all right?
- I promised you I was
going to do it at the end,
(Burgess laughs loudly) but
wait, let's back up a little bit
because you hit a couple of things there.
- Okay.
- So you mentioned the
greatest generation,
and you're talking about how
so much of what's happening now
seems to be an eraser of past.
So you've had a pretty amazing past.
You were one of the first
three black football players
at University of Miami,
everybody knows about the
incredible football history there.
Can you just back up
first and just tell us
a little bit about where you're from,
what your folks were like,
just growing up, all that kind of stuff?
- I would love to because this is probably
the biggest pride I have is my upbringing,
and because so many people don't
know about it is a shocker.
It's important to realize,
the message of my background
is very simply this;
This country will give anyone
the opportunity to get to the
middle class if we understand the tenets
that we need to get there.
And it doesn't matter how poor we come,
what color we are,
how little we understand language.
If we understand it's all
about education, faith,
industry and family, we got it.
So that being said, (clears
throat) the black community,
because they understood those tenets,
the 40s, 50s, and 60s,
led our country in the
growth of the middle class,
men matriculating at college,
men committed to a marriage,
over 70%, and the percentage
of our entrepreneurs.
we had in our communities,
business owners everywhere.
Keep in mind, there were no
white people in my community,
so everything was driven
by black entrepreneurs.
That black entrepreneurship--
Where'd you grow up?
- In Tallahassee.
Tallahassee, Florida, deep South.
Tallahassee days of KKK
Jim Crow, segregation.
I didn't have my first
interaction with white Americans
until I was 16 years old, (clears throat)
but I grew up in a community who were
so proud of who they were.
Our dads came back from war.
They were proud of who they were.
I was taught, never let
that flag touch the ground
it will be desecrated, I
was really proud of that.
(clears throat)
But the most important thing
is that the 40% of business
ownership equated to over
50 to 60% of black Americans
across our country,
DC, Dirty South, Texas, California.
We had relatives all across the board,
all part of the middle class,
and that was the way our
country was, our race was.
(clears throat) That has
been flipped upside down
where we now have 3.8% business ownership,
and that's, of course, our
middle class is going down,
and the unfortunate most important thing
about the middle class, most
of it now is becoming elitists.
They have a great big group of elitists,
a bigger group of poor,
and a very small group
of that very empathetic, loving, serving,
outside-the-box-thinking middle class,
so we have to get that back.
And, Dave, I'll tell you,
if I can just warn our fellow Americans
what the real attack is, (clears throat)
the real value we're fighting right now,
obviously, is all culture,
but what the left wants to do
is destroy our middle class.
Why?
Because the middle class is
the stakeholder of our culture.
That's where we find
the best of Americans.
Those who are going out there,
they work, they pay their
bills, they pay their payroll,
they dream, they fail,
they step back up again,
and their goal is very simple,
to build something and give
to their kids, a legacy.
And here's the other piece
of it. (clears throat)
Business owners realize one thing.
When customers come through their door,
they know they have a
discipline to be a nice person.
Why? Because they want
them to come back again.
Even if they are knuckleheads,
they want them to come back
and keep buying their product.
(Dave laughs)
That is in essence what
draws people to our country.
(clears throat)
The bigger that middle class is,
the more vibrant our freedom really is,
and the more educated we
are and the whole bit,
and that's what they're after.
That's why we look at their covert,
what they were trying to do,
these Marxists, (clears throat)
these folks who are totally heartless
because they've never understood
what it is to build a business.
They want to shut down our economy,
shut down businesses, make sure they fail.
Why? Because at the end of the day,
they want a power in November.
(clears throat)
These mayors allow these
thugs that come through
these black communities and
every four years destroy them.
Destroy their infrastructure.
Why?
Because those black
business owners will become,
they're lifting themselves
out of that poverty
to the middle lass.
So this is what we're after.
If we understand that, then
we understand our enemy,
and the enemy is not us.
There's not a Republican
or Democrats independence,
it's those who truly
adhere to an evil ideology
of socialism and Marxism,
and because they do, they can care less.
They have no heart for
anybody else, but themselves,
and they don't mind.
And in my case, with the black community,
they will use, abuse and discard
because that's what it
takes for them to continue
to win their battle.
- As somebody that grew up
in the segregated South,
Jim Crow laws,
and you mentioned you didn't
really have interactions
with white America, let's
say, till you're 16 years old,
you know, then you become an NFL star.
You're playing in college
and you're NFL star,
Super Bowl champion,
have done all sorts of
other stuff since then.
Are you shocked that in 2020,
right now as we talk
that we seemingly at our,
what the media would tell you is
our worst race relations in decades.
I don't think it's actually true,
I think it's just the way
that it's being framed
and pushed on us,
but are you shocked at sort
of the moment that we're at
right now?
- Well, (clears throat) I
guess I can't say I'm shocked
because I know the enemy is tenacious.
(clears throat)
They just don't give up.
There's no shame.
So what I think we're finding out, though,
is how deep into our institutions
that they have given their
diet, they've gotten into.
When I talk about termites,
they've been doing this
for a long long time.
I've seen it with our educational system.
I just had no idea how
broad their tentacles work
that we're seeing it coming from
every single angle that you have,
including within our bureaucracy,
the government that we thought we trusted.
You know, I never thought
that the FBI, the DOJ,
all of those things were
complicit in this process.
(clears throat)
But then if you understand again,
a little bit about
Marxism and a socialists,
they're cowards and
bullies, (clears throat)
so we really shouldn't be surprised.
They're the ones that
are gonna try to find
the softest place to do their business,
to do their job.
They want to keep covered.
They don't want to be fired.
So if you find a place that's
very safe, you'll find them.
Whether it'd be a college or tenure,
or these, you know, these government jobs
where nobody knows who they are
and they never get fired,
or, of course, the media,
where they get into media organizations.
All they have to do is
be as far left as you can
and they got a secure job.
So that's ( clears throat)
what we're fighting against.
And the downside to being entrepreneurs
between those who are total optimist,
we sometimes forget to get into the weeds.
You know, where we're
not going to be drawn
to the same things they are.
We are out there taking risks,
you know, building our dreams,
falling and getting back up.
And all we want to be done
is just to be left alone.
Let us do our thing and
just leave us alone.
(clears throat)
But while we're doing that,
then behind the curtains
all this is going on,
(clears throat)
and sometimes-- Do you think
that's what the fundamental
disconnect in society right now is?
I think it has something to do with that.
That there's a certain set of people,
I actually think most Americans
who just want to live and let live,
they want some basic policies
that keep the government out
of their lives, but that's pretty much it.
But when you believe that,
you're not going to be
riled up all the time
and angry and on the attack all the time,
and now we have a new set of people.
I don't think it's as many as the other,
but I think that they're
loud and vociferous
and and on the attack,
and so they seem
disproportionately powerful
because the rest of us, we're
working, we're watching TV,
we're doing stuff with our
families, whatever it might be,
so that there's a disconnect there
in the parody of both sides.
- (clears throat) It is,
but that's the nature of who we are,
and it takes...
Keep in mind, remember what we we're doing
911 and the Pearl Harbor.
We were going about our business,
and one day on a sunny
day, going to church
or going to work.
We had no idea how much we were hated
until thousands of us had
to die through the process,
but what happens once the enemy hits,
we wake up and realize
what we're up against,
and that's when we become
dangerous to the enemy.
As the Japanese, whatever, admiral said,
I feel we're waking a sleeping
giant. (clears throat)
I believe what's happened right now.
There are Americans across this country
who do not like what they're seeing.
They don't want to see cities burned.
They don't wanna see people being beat up.
We hate bullies to our core,
and we might not be
saying anything about it,
we might not be polling
because we just aren't into
that, but we as a country,
always do the right things
at the right time for the right reasons.
I personally think, Dave,
the reason why President Trump,
candidate Trump was elected in 2016
because we as a country
just innately understood
something Wasn't right,
we definitely didn't want
the other person to win,
even though we didn't know
a lot about President Trump,
(clears throat) but at the end of the day,
now that we do see it,
and we see him standing for rule of law,
we see him pulling
together the free market,
and the government broken things out.
Even more importantly,
we see him working against
these bullies (clears throat)
that no other president
has done since Reagan.
I mean, Reagan had a
different style about it
because the word is, I guess, mean,
I don't know if it's
the word for it or more,
(clears throat)
but he's the guy, the
only one right now that I
understand could ever do what he's doing
every single day getting up
because these guys again, are relentless,
and they have no shame,
and they just love to lie.
At the end of the day, for them,
lying is part of getting to the end game.
So we have to understand that.
I think that's what our
country is getting to,
and I truly believe, Dave,
that we're going to come
right out of this just fine.
I think, for the first time,
that's why as I'm running for Congress,
which I never ever thought
I'd ever do, (clears throat)
(Dave laughs)
but I'm working with kids.
My mission has always been
working with at-risk kids
that's what I was doing,
but I realized if we don't
win up back the house,
the kids I work with
and across the country,
don't have a chance because
it's always policies
that make them illiterate,
hopeless, jobless, angry.
It's always policies,
and it's democratic policies
that are doing that.
So where I see this very simply,
we have about 18, 19 seats we need.
I've looked at across the
country. (clears throat)
I've seen these congressional candidates,
and they're like me.
Many of them have never done this before,
but they're not going there to get
a permanent seat in Congress,
or to be a lobbyist down the road.
They're there to replicate the president,
who is showing us what true
American loving leadership looks like.
For the first time for many of us
to see what it takes to really
fight against the bullies.
We're going to get this
new group in there,
and we're going to make changes
that has never been seen before
because we'll be there
for the right reasons.
We're going to start tackling things
that we've always had to,
but we've had to either deal
with elitist Republicans
or elitists Democrats,
and nothing ever gets cut and done
When you talk with those kinds of people.
(clears throat) We're going to
start looking at our budget,
balancing our budget.
Do something with our healthcare system
that gives it a transparency
and a competitive nature
that brings it down.
How about social security?
Being able to figure out,
how do we keep our promises
with those who are older
and had promises made,
and give our young people that opportunity
to do something so much better
by the time they get to retirement
because they can own the process.
Those are conversations
we're going to finally have.
So we'll come there, and I'm
going to put this out there.
I see us as a seal team. (laughs)
The seal team. (clears throat)
We're there to disrupt some stuff,
and we'll make that happen,
and not only will our presence
strengthen the backbone of our Senate,
which we need more backbone,
but allow our president, for
the first time in four years
to run forward without having his hands
tied behind his back.
So I see this could be
the greatest renaissance
for our country that we've ever seen
because all of the country,
all of America can take part,
no matter what the color,
creed or background.
We can all be part of
this new growth of America
and just really just enjoy
the process together.
- You know, it's funny you
describe it as a seal team
because I had, Dan Crenshaw,
Congressman down in Texas,
who I'm sure you know,
and I had him on and I
described him, it's like
you know, he's like a solo superhero
fighting against the squad.
You know, they've got
their Legion of doom team,
but he's kind of a solo guy
and he needs some new help in Congress,
and I think that's what
you're talking about.
Before we go too much on the policy side
because I was on your website this morning
and you lay out all your
political beliefs, actually,
very clearly, it's all there,
but before we do the policy stuff,
I just want to do a little
bit more on your history
because as I said earlier,
you're one of the three
first black people football
players at University of Miami,
and then let's talk a little bit about NFL
and just sort of how the sports mindset,
and going for a championship
and winning and all that stuff.
How did that set you up as a human being?
- Okay, (clears throat) good question.
Let me just, first of all,
kind of put in context,
the environment of NFL when
I joined as opposed to today
because I think the
biggest part of us being
excited about our future
is knowing about our past,
and it was something that, Carl
Mark said that said it all.
The first Browder ground
is rewriting your history.
If they steal our past,
we truly do not have an
appreciation for where we are
and we have no vision
for where we're going.
(clears throat)
So that being in context,
again, I grew up in the Deep
South, there's a segregation.
At 12 years old, I remember marching.
I was the youngest person at that time.
I was with the Florida
Indian when my dad was
a college professor.
In front of Florida state theater
because we couldn't go in to
look at a movies theater there.
(clears throat)
My dad... You know, just
a little extra background.
My dad actually came back from war
a very proud world war II vet.
Could not go to get his
postgraduate down in Texas
because of the Jim Crow laws,
and I remember running
across a box of letters
when he passed away of all
these rejection letters
that had gotten across the country
that would not accept
him to those colleges.
And I looked through it and I
realize it's a racist thing,
but he never ever brought it out.
He'd never talked about it.
For him, it was motivation, (laughs)
and that's what those folks do.
There was motivation.
He ended up going to a house state
where he's got his PhD.
He ended up being a 40
year professor there,
and was an entrepreneur, researched,
and we traveled around the world.
I was five years old,
living in Liberia, Africa.
- Wow!
- Again, that's the environment.
This is the 50s.
I had an older uncle, and by the way,
he had his older brother, both
got their PhDs at Ohio state.
Dad got in Agronomy, uncle
Lima, got it in Economics.
He ended up teaching at
the University of Houston.
(clears throat)
Their oldest brother was
probably the smartest one.
He was an engineer and he loved planes,
but he couldn't do that
when he went to service.
So on a part time base he
ended buying a little...
This was 1962.
Nobody bought planes in 1962, (laughs)
particularly, black folks,
but he bought a little plane
and because he was entrepreneurial,
he was an engineer, but he
lived in Wichita Falls, Texas.
He took letters from Wichita Falls base,
the military based in Chicago,
that was the start time business,
the first FedEx. (laughs)
And I remember him coming,
flying to Tallahassee,
and I must have been maybe 12 years old
when I had my first
flight in an aeroplane.,
and I remember that experience very well
because he took me up
and I don't know if you
know what the stall...
I'm sure you know what stall
means, what it's all about,
but if you don't know what a stall means,
it's good to know before you stall
or before you get the experience.
(Dave laughs) It feels like
falling out of the air,
and I remember stalling, getting panicked,
and he kind of got control,
smiled at me and taught
me what airplane lift was.
I know today exactly what
airplane lift means. (laughs)
But I'm making that point--
It ain't fun, either way.
- No. No
I'm making that point
because I want people to know
that my community was truly
one of the most competitive
communities in our country,
one they were so proud of.
We educated ourselves because we knew
that's what we needed to do to compete.
My degree was in biology,
my minor was chemistry.
Why was I comfortable do that?
Because my dad was a cosmic fester.
He had a laboratory, I
feel very comfortable,
and the most important thing
is when I was told by someone
in high school that I could
not do that, I made it my duty.
I lived in the library
of University of Miami
to prove that guy wrong
because that's the
attitude we had those days.
(clears throat)
So that was the environment.
Again, I went through University of Miami.
I was drafted through
the Jets. (clears throat)
When I got to the Jets,
this is the way it was in those days.
There was no black quarterbacks, centers,
pre-safeties or middle linebackers.
In those days the message
of the democratic party
was that black people couldn't think.
We were not leaders.
We could run, we could
jump, we could play music,
but thinking was out of our
wheelhouse. (clears throat)
By the way, to that point.
When you go back and
see Martin Luther King,
and you see the marching.
I want you now to keep this
in context when you see them,
you'll notice he has
white shirts, black ties,
sometimes business caps
and always business shoes
because they were going
against the narrative
of the leftist, of the racist,
of illiterate,
lazy, bumpkins, can't talk,
all of the negatives you
can possibly think of,
and they were showing
in the way they marched
and the discipline and non-violent
that they were totally off base,
and they wanted to make
sure their kids understood
not to take the narrative of
these people, not to be
proud of who you are.
So I just want to put that in there.
So when I think back about
when I came to the NFL.
- What year was your rookie year?
- 1973. (clears throat) 1973.
I now look at in NFL now
that's based on meritocracy,
color doesn't matter.
That means no matter what color you are,
how fat, how big you are,
if you can bring merit to that team,
you'll get yourself a good contract.
That speaks volumes that people understand
how far we've come, then all of a sudden,
then we're a racist place
doesn't work anymore.
I mean, I know what racism look like.
I know what systemic racism looks like.
We have an opportunity right
now to do anything we want to.
I can not only go into a theater,
I can own a series of them if I wanted to,
but it comes down to
recognizing (clears throat)
that the differential
and every single race, every single person
that translates to success is
based on those four tenets.
Very simple to understand,
and I think it's time that we find a way
to explain conservatism,
explain the American way,
the entree to the middle class, simply.
We spend too much time
trying to debate it,
but it comes to the four tenets;
Head, heart, hands and home.
Education, faith, industry and family.
It's that simple.
If we educate ourselves,
we no longer can be manipulated
by the leftist who wants
to keep us dumb and motivated by emotion.
If we understand that faith
is the answer to everything,
this is a country that was built
on Judeo-Christian values, period,
and no matter how we worship him,
the reason why we look
at each other inside-out
versus outside-in better
than any other country
is because we believe
there's a God in heaven
that makes us want to bless.
We want the blessings by blessing others.
Industry; We now understand as a country
that we are not that country
that wants a 10 months
vacation, that's just not us.
We want to work.
We want to sweat.
we want to, man, fall flat and get back up
because we feel good about the process.
That's who we are and
that's why we've always led
the entire world in terms
of producing things,
that's in the DNA of our American people.
The last but not least is our family.
The family unit (clears throat) dictates
where our country goes
and how high we fly,
and that's why the leftist has
been after us for a long time
destroying the family unit.
We should always think about, very simply,
the way I was brought up,
the best thing I could do
is I wanna make sure that my family's name
is one that's respected.
It's a legacy for my dad, my mom.
If I do the kind of things,
where they are proud of
that I carried their name
and I do the same through to my kids
then We have done a great
deed for our country
and for my family and for my race,
and as a citizen, that all works out.
So the family is really the key point
and it would just have
to get back to understanding what that is
or what the roles might be
and all that kind of stuff.
That's a long answer to a short question,
but I hope I got there, buddy.
(laughs loudly)
- I think you got there.
- Okay.
- So you mentioned the
meritocracy of the NFL now,
and I think that goes obviously
for all professional sports
at this point.
Nobody cares what color you are,
it's can you play?
I mean, and for me, I'm a basketball guy,
but when I played ball my entire life,
any court that I showed up to,
nobody cared if you were
white or black or Asian
or anything else,
what do you care about?
Can the guy put the ball in the hole?
That's the only thing that you care about.
And there is a certain--
Just win, baby. (laughs)
- Yeah, just win, baby, that's it.
There's a certain beauty
and a simplicity to that,
but when you see things,
you know, how politicized
sports has become.
So you may remember about a year ago,
there was a big thing in the NBA that
the players didn't want the
owners to call them owners
because that somehow had some connotations
to slavery or something,
but the simple fact is they own the team.
I mean, they own the
team, that's how it works.
When you hear these things
and you hear it from people
that are multi-millionaires
that make money
that you could never do.
Do you remember how much
you made your rookie year?
- Oh, (laughs loudly) I'm almost ashamed,
but keep in mind,
first round draft choice, get ready.
First round draft choice, the 13th pick,
the first defensive back.
My bonus was 50,000,
and I made 23, 25 or 27,
the first three years,
and those last three,
- Wow!
those years were not
guaranteed, by the way,
had to go out and make that happen,
- Right.
- But now, it's crazy
- Now guys you get, like,
an eight-year guaranteed
100 million.
- It's crazy.
- But really,
when you hear these guys say
these sorts of things,
and fight about these sorts of things,
and then suddenly they won't
say anything about China
at the same exact time.
We had a big problem with that in the NBA
because they want
lucrative deals over there
and contracts and all that.
What do you make as far as what's happened
in the sports world?
- There's two things,
there's two parts of it.
I'm going to highlight
the middle class ones,
and then I'll get back
to the culture piece.
(clears throat)
The first thing is
this is what the biggest problem
with my community, my race,
is that we went through
this great middle class
built on small business ownerships
to a great elitist class,
built by entertainment and government.
When people do not do not
work their way through
the middle class and
understand what it takes
to make it, to strive,
to finally get to where
you feel comfortable
you can reach back,
then you become elitist.
And what happens,
you go from dirt poor to super rich.
You really do believe you're all that.
I mean, it's very easy
to get into that mindset
that you truly are, you
know what answers you want.
Think about, LeBron.
LeBron knows he's a
great basketball player,
but he also knows the
answers to everything else.
(Dave laughs)
The guy is so smart.
If you ask him, he's so
bold and is never wrong,
(clears throat)
but that's what happens with
elitist, there's no balance.
- He got pretty quiet on China, though,
don't forget.
- Oh, yeah.
- China, he suddenly didn't know much.
- Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah.
So that's the one piece is, unfortunately,
we have too many elitists
who don't get it,
and they will never understand
what we're trying to go through.
The other part of this is very simply,
our culture has been under
attack for a long time.
When you take away the family,
you take away our faith of God,
you take away things, very
simple things like respect.
One thing that we had in our
community a day very simply,
respect the God, country and family,
and most of all, women.
Never ever,
don't even let that thought
go through your mind,
even start going through
your ear of disrespecting mom
because dad would be there
to make it right, big time.
So when you don't understand
those basic respects,
you don't understand that when
you're dealing with a coach,
he's truly the coach.
I mean, we came through an
era where the coach was...
You know, he told you something,
you didn't sit there and
argue and fight with him.
We have a thing where things
just have turned upside down,
where literally the players
are driving the team,
the players are dictating
to the commissioner,
what they're going to do and
what they're not going to do.
And of course we have towers
like the commissioner who is...
We can maybe talk about this,
but, Goodell is nothing,
but he's going to be known in history as
the Bill de Blasio of commissioners.
(Dave laughs)
This guy is hapless,
and half the problem
is that it's on purpose
because he's truly a true leftist
that wants to use the
sport to push their agenda
and make it work out so
that at the end of the day,
they get Democrats in place.
It's all about power when
you deal with these leftists,
and de Blasio, I mean, I'm sorry,
Goodell is no difference. (laughs)
He's all about power.
He wants to use these
kids, who have no clue
dive into the social justice
was nothing but Marxism
so that when they were creating
all this anger and angst,
and riots within the community,
so they go out and vote in November.
These people are truly heartless,
and they don't think
they'll ever be found out
because they're always
hiding behind the curtain,
but we know,
we're beginning to understand
what this person is.
This person driving the NFL,
and I'll tell you what,
if they go the route of
what they did before,
either kneeling or the
latest thing that I've heard
is going to put the
black lives matter flag
beneath our flag.
If he does either one of those
two, we're done with NFL,
and we won't be coming back
and that's going to be a
good thing to see happen.
- Urgh! You know, it's such
a crazy thing for, I mean,
for a Super Bowl champion, football player
to say that that would be a good thing.
It's crazy, but I understand
where you're coming from,
but are you ever shocked...
I mean, I get what your
feelings are about the Marxists
and the idea of destruction and all that,
but are you ever shocked
that a guy like Goodell,
who I assume enjoys football,
I assume he enjoys business, right?
He may have the wrong ideas,
but I think, you know, if we
separate that for a second,
but the lengths that they'll go
to destroy their own enterprise,
I mean, I think we see this,
we see this across the sports,
but it does seem to be worse in the NFL.
I think David Silver has done
a much better job in the NBA
of sort of keeping the
wheels on the thing,
although, we talked about
the China thing a moment ago,
baseball, for some reason,
they don't seem to have
major issues with this.
There's something going on
in the NFL that does seem
particularly different.
- I'm going to give you a little insight
of what's happening. I think
you'll get it. (clears throat)
I think you'll understand
that as we play checkers,
these guys play chess.
Goodell is a globalist,
and a globalist as
someone who looks himself
as a world citizen
versus American citizen,
and in their game,
as long as they can get
as much money coming in
from wherever they might
get it, they're okay.
(clears throat)
And what's happened is
over the last few years,
the NFL has been looking
at going into other parts
of the country, China being one.
They have little China
teams they're working on.
They're now going to England
looking to have a Super Bowl
there in another couple of years.
So they see a global market
that is going to be...
Right now, they've capped
out around 14 billion.
He's projecting by 2027
it'll be up to 25 billion.
Now, where are they
going to get that extra?
It's not here in America
because they're pretty much capped out.
It's that TV, it's the global process,
and here's the devious part about it.
Because it's not just the
global facet that, you know,
we can kind of understand
as a business owner.
For these guys, it's more than that.
They have to devalue the NFL brand first
before China will accept it.
The NFL brand is all American.
It's our flag, it's our country.
I mean, that's why we stand together
because we understand this is...
Matter of fact, the founders of the NFL,
most of them were world war II vets.
So when they came out and
they developed this concept,
they was all about the country.
Well, if they're going
to do this in China,
they have to demean
that brand a little bit,
and so that's why right now,
Nike, which is the marketing arm for NFL,
guess what the face of the
NFL is now around the world?
It's Component.
The Marxists Component.
He was paid.
This face is there.
So when it comes down to branding now,
they can now make the money
they have to make outside
of our country,
and, of course, keep the
American people moving on
and keep the kind of a solid base here,
and one of the things,
Dave, just so you know,
that the last contract is
signed for $40 million per year.
90% of that is based on
growth incentives, 90%.
So that says a lot, but
he feels very comfortable.
He felt very confident that
he could make enough money,
some kind of way or growth to
bring that kind of income in.
At the end of the day,
kind of the problem right now (laughs)
is China did their deal,
and all of a sudden, China's
not too attractive anymore
and this is going to kind of upset
our apple cart a little bit.
I think he might have to reconsider
how he's going to get that done.
But if that's it, if you
understand that process
that these people truly are
not thinking the way we do
as Americans that love our country,
they think in a different way,
then maybe you understand
why they don't mind
turning off the American
fan to make more income
and look at the global market
in a little bit different way.
- It's so interesting because obviously,
you know, I know about globalists
and the idea of one world
and all that,
but I've never heard of the
framing relative to the NFL
that we've got to grow.
We have these projections,
we got to do it.
We've maxed out America.
So now we have to sort of crush
our own brand in a weird way
to export it over there.
- Kind of amazing.
it's pretty fascinating.
And then the 40 million,
if it's mostly on incentives,
you can sort of see how whacked out.
All right, let's move a little bit here.
- Okay.
- Let let's talk about Utah
because I've had a couple of people from
the great state of Utah on,
and I've only been to Utah once, actually,
when I was on tour with Jordan
Peterson a year or two ago,
and we did a show there and
I did some stand up there,
and I walked into the
standup club, and I was like,
"I don't know what I'm
walking into exactly.
"It's gonna be 500 Mormons, you know.
"Are they going to have
a good sense of humor?"
(Burgess laughs)
You know, really,
- Yeah.
- And truly it was one of...
I write about it in my book.
It was one of the best nights of my life.
So many, it was in Salt Lake City,
but just so many,
absolutely wonderful people.
Fan laughing, laughing at themselves.
It was just an absolute blast.
Tell me a little bit about...
people don't know much about, Utah.
If you mentioned Utah to
people, I think most people,
they think of skiing,
they think of Karl Malone,
and they think of Mormons.
- Yeah.
Tell me a little bit more
about Utah.
- Well, (clears throat)
the most important thing,
we talked earlier about the
middle class and what drives it,
that's small business ownership.
In Utah, there's too much
of 77,000 businesses,
99% of those are small business owners.
So that says a lot about why
the culture is the way it is.
We are a culture.
Basically, I'd say three things;
solution, service and surplus.
We are very entrepreneurial,
we're always thinking outside the box,
trying to figure out how
to make good things happen
so we can get some wealth
for ourselves to give away.
Service; We love to serve.
We are the community that
literally gets excited
about kids going off to some
crazy international place
that nobody wants to visit
(laughs) to serve for two years,
and we're excited about it. (laughs)
So we do that because we
understand that one thing
that brings us together,
and that's why this country
is gonna come together
in a big way when we get through this,
we fall in love with each
other when we serve each other.
That's the end of the game.
That's what it comes down to.
So we are very service culture.
The last one is this,
we love to give back.
We love to take out extra
time and money to give back.
What I love about being
here to me is home.
I've been talking about
the community I grew up in
the deep South, Tallahassee,
when all I knew were black entrepreneurs,
black coaches, black professors,
black business owners,
and everybody's saying,
you can do it.
You can make it. Our goal was
to become the best race ever
and show those guys wrong.
Well, growing up in that community,
and now I had the same values,
so I feel really at home.
It's really about those
things I talked about.
God, country, family, respect,
thinking outside the box service.
And I'll just say this,
this is why this district
that I'm running in is so important,
for those who are watching,
why is district four important
to the rest of the country?
Because this is between one and three
of must have at both parties.
The Democrats must have this.
Right now, they own it by Ben McAdams.
It's a plus 13 Republican district,
it never should have gone
Democrat, but it did.
So the Democrats must have
it to keep their power,
and you see what they
do when they get power.
We must have it to get our country back.
To get back to the culture
we've been talking about.
I feel very very proud and
blessed to represent a district
that can truly be the
linchpin of our country.
You know, I talked a bit
earlier about what can happen
once we get the house back.
This seat can get it done.
And we get our seal team
together because of this district
that has the values we have,
and I could be no more
pleased to be in a position
that we can actually help
do that for our country
to finally start winning
again in a big way.
- What kind of traction are you getting?
Because, you know, it's funny
the way Twitter operates,
you know, I see certain personalities
that will bubble up for a while,
and then I'll click a profile.
I'll go, oh, this guy is
running for Congress in Utah,
this girl's running for
something in Florida,
or something else.
And you're kind of like,
Oh, well, they're sort
of popular on Twitter
or they make sense here,
but it's a little hard
to tell as an outsider.
Well, is this gaining traction at home?
How can you grade sort of
where your campaign is at?
Are there weak spots that
you want to shore up?
You know, that kind of thing.
- Very good.(clears throat)
I think the blessings that
I've had (clears throat)
is that I never thought
about being a politician
all these years.
I mean, literally it did not happen until
probably this time last year.
So up until this point,
I came out with a book,
the (mumbles) was "Liberalism
or How to Turn Good Men
"into Whiners, Weenies and Wimps,"
and that got me on, just around
the same time that (laughs)
the company... Yes, it was
a good time, it really is,
but it's just about the same time
that company was doing it's kneeling,
but I had a chance to get
on and share with America,
my thoughts, my pride in country,
and what I saw as really
being detrimental.
So I had a chance to
develop some friendships
throughout the time,
and so now that I'm running,
I really have an opportunity
to have exposure,
that's been very advantageous for me.
We have a community again
because we're very conservative
that looks at Fox.
So many people knew me somewhat,
even though I was in a very small niche.
I was working with at-risk kids,
so I wasn't out in the
community a whole lot,
but it's been an opportunity
for me to, first of all,
to really know this
district a lot more than
I would have ever.
I know our state a lot better
because I'm now out talking with people.
And what I'm finding
(clears throat) is that
my message resonates.
We all just want to have
somebody who's willing to stand,
and not wilt, and not feel
ashamed and not apologize.
And I'll tell you, at the end of the day,
when God, country, family and race
is the most important
thing before anything else,
it's easy to stand. (laughs)
It really is, no big deal.
Because if that's being attacked,
then you want to run to make
sure you protect all the above,
and that's what I'm finding
out across our country.
We have conservatives that really get it.
They don't mind taking the hit,
they don't mind being called names
because it doesn't mean a thing.
Matter of fact, I tell
people to call me names.
Make sure you're using your time right
because it doesn't impact me.
You might be wasting a lot of time
because it doesn't bother me at all.
(Dave laughs)
So together, we get that group together,
and we give this message to those, again,
who's been truly used
over the last few months,
or abused over the last few months.
I think we have a point that
we can start to resonate
and say, yes, you know guys,
lets work together to get our
economy back to where it was
a few months ago and this time
know who the enemy is and never go back,
and I think that's what we'll
come out of this process with.
- Yeah.
So as I said, I was on
your website this morning,
and I was looking at the
issues that you knock out one at a time.
Let's just do two or three
that you're particularly passionate about.
I'll even toss them up to you.
Give me two or three that
you really care about
that you think are the core
issues that can help you win.
- Very good, Dave.
Again, everything that I'm working with
is based on those promises;
life, liberty, and pursuit of happiness,
that's the bottom line.
For us to understand that,
we have to be educated.
"Ignorant and free can
never be," Thomas Jefferson.
That is so powerful.
And the leftists understood
that a long time,
that's why they work very hard
to make sure we stay ignorant.
It's the left and we're
talking about true evil.
When you work diligently to keep people
hopeless and uneducated,
that's what I call evil.
If you go to the state of California,
where 75% of black boys in the
state of California in 2017,
cannot pass standard
reading and writing tests.
When young people cannot read and write,
we're not going to talk about Space Corps,
we're not going to have
conversations like this.
We're going to turn on the
network and be driven by emotion
because they have no
hope, no way of thinking,
no way of reasoning, they'll
never read the scriptures,
the connection with our God in heaven
would never ever happen. (clear's throat)
And you go to every single threshold,
every single city that's
owned by the leftist,
by the Democrats,
you've seen the exact same thing;
Hopelessness, anger, and illiteracy.
So education is going to be a big piece.
Now, the other part of education
is that what they've done
in higher education.
See, it's not just the poor
kids that are being attacked,
it's the rest of our kids,
it's our middle class.
When we raise our kids
in a great environment,
we send them off to get a degree,
they come back as a little
Marxists, hating our country,
and not being able to think
at all about reasoning.
They have been doing this for so long
and now you see it in the streets,
across the country, and Tepa.
They're not black kids.
They're middle class yuppie.
You know, in my days
yuppies was what was cool,
I don't know if it's still
cool anymore, (laughs)
but they're kids who have the wealth,
but they hate our country.
What I think we should
do is very simply this,
I (mumbles) this earlier.
Lets put together a program,
an understanding of what
is expected about colleges.
They want our money.
First of all, we have to see transparency.
How much are they succeeding,
and what areas do we need as a country.
If they don't hit those
matrix, we get our money,
we take it back and
put it some place else.
So education is the first thing.
One of the things that
just warmed my heart,
really warmed my heart.
When I saw the riots in Minneapolis,
they had this video of these black owners,
black businesses just next to each other.
- [Dave] Oh, yeah.
- Yeah, and then in the
window, "Black owned,"
big black owned,
and this was an opportunity for all of us
to see what a Passover looks like.
Because the locusts and
the pillage of looters
passed over these businesses.
Why?
because it (murmurs) our 50s sitting there
on his store to these kids knowing that
if you show up here, you're
gonna have some issues.
They passed by to go to those companies,
those businesses that still
believe in the bureaucracy is
gonna save them.
So those are the two
top things is education.
Educational allow us to
have that mindset to go out
and build our own businesses,
build our property, which is important.
The pursuit of happiness was in place
for pursuit of property.
Whether that property
will be tangible property,
intellectual property,
spiritual property passed
down to our kids, our name.
Those things we work our lives to build,
at the end of the day on our last breath,
we should be able to say,
I'm so glad I lived
because this is my legacy.
That's what a property truly means.
In order to protect that,
we need to be educated to
think about what it looks like,
and have the vision to get there.
We also have to have the tools to protect
every single step of the way
so that nobody can come in
and steal it from us.
And we now understand, when
we talk about needing to have
that ability, go to the cities
where they would just let loose,
evil will just let loose in these cities,
and we start to see what
it really looks like
and we can never let that
happen in our lifetime.
- Do you think that that mindset
of how to conquer all of this
is really the same mindset,
whether you're an entrepreneur
or a professional athlete,
or a politician that really
wants to change things properly,
that it is purely a mindset of,
I am going to dedicate
myself to this relentlessly
and see it fit?
And maybe that's why you can
see it as a former NFL player,
where some people can't quite see it.
Because, you know, there's this
idea that somehow victimhood
gives you virtue these days,
or can't someone else do it,
or the rules are so against
me that I can't do it,
but it's like, if we think
of all of our heroes,
our sports heroes or
fictional heroes, they did it.
They said it doesn't matter
how messed up the game is,
I'm going to win.
I'm going to fix it.
- And you know,
that's what comes out of
a healthy environment.
That's what came out of
my community growing up.
Well, we had the idea of, first of all,
life is not always called fair.
Life is difficult, and there
are people who are going to try
to slow you down,
but if you have the tenacity,
you can dream because
you've educated yourself
to know this is possible,
and you have the faith to know that
you're just as special as anybody else,
then we can overcome those obstacles.
The problem we're having in my community,
and we're now having
it across the country,
and I say this as often
as I can. (clears throat)
What destroyed my community
was turning it upside down
till we see kids now that
are acting like victims
and is destroying their own properties.
It was not white supremacist,
it has never has been white supremacists.
We beat out white supremacists,
it's been black leaders.
It's been those with stealth,
those who look like me,
those who talk like me,
those who put their arms around and say,
you know, we're going to make
things right and make things
so it's all fair, and they sell out.
They go in, they go to Congress,
the black caucus, the
NAACP, (clears throat)
you name them, the elitist.
Instead of giving us hope and
telling us what we can do,
they purposely put in place impediments.
They put in laws that make sure
the poor cannot become middle class.
They make sure that our poor
black kids could never be
educated.
Why?
Because they're stuck,
because of this anti-choice that these
black leaders will vote for and stand for
and see their people destroyed
because they don't care.
So it is truly elitism across
the board that's our enemy,
(clears throat)
and I'll say this,
if we go ahead and educate ourselves,
not to what the propaganda of the leftist,
educate ourselves to our history,
educate ourselves to what
we the people have done.
I tell you, Dave, if we did that,
let me just real quick story.
I would never ever...
Ever...
Well, I'm not a racist, I never will be,
but my point is, but particularly
for our German and Mexican-Americans,
will ever look down or
feel bad about that race,
those people.
Why?
Because when my great
great grandfather came here
in the belly of a slave ship,
he escaped South Carolina plantation,
the Burgess plantation,
they went to Southern and Western route
of the underground railroad.
Guess who was making that happen?
Christian German-Americans
and Mexican-Americans
that opened their doors,
opened their fields, fed them,
gave them hope along the way,
and what happened on that trip out West,
not only did my great great grandfather
understand he could make
great things happen,
but he was able to forgive
and went on to be a
successful entrepreneur.
He owned 102 acres of land
that he bought in two years,
a pillar of his community
because along the way, this travel,
he realized that all
white people aren't bad.
There are good people out there,
and he had to be a Christian.
He started the first
black elementary school
and first black church.
My point is this.
Once we learn the stories
of what we've done together,
we find that happening all over the place.
It's not a special case.
We have always done that,
but we have to educate
ourselves to that point,
and once we do that,
we can break loose of this,
the racist process that's been put upon us
by the democratic party.
- That my friend is what
America is all about, I think.
I think, am I pretty close?
(Burgess laughs)
- You got it.
(clears throat)
That's who we are.
And the most powerful words
in the history of mankind
that we sometimes just throw out there
and we don't quite get.
It's never been done this way.
It's three empowering words
that has span an experiment
that is truly given us
freedom to the entire world,
"We the people."
"We the people," very simply says
that we control our future,
We can divide everything,
about our family,
our business, our jobs,
how we deal with people,
and we together collectively
can elect a president
in 2016 that nobody saw coming. (laughs)
We could figure out some things
that we have no idea how we did.
I mean, how did we do that, seriously?
There were so many doubts out there.
How did we pull that one off? (laughs)
Because-- Well, listen,
- Anyway we pulled it off.
- I know you didn't
want to be a politician,
but now I'm going to see
if you're doing it properly
because I'm going to
give you the last word
to pimp out your website,
and your own campaign,
- Okay (laughs)
- And the whole thing.
Let's see it. Let's see it.
- Thank you for this opportunity, Dave.
Burgess for Utah.
Please join us.
Please support us.
Let's get our Congress back.
Let's get this seal team in place,
and lets win our country,
and just win, baby, we can
do that again, for sure.
- I look forward to seeing
you again, my friend.
We'll do Gutfeld again, I'm sure,
and you know, next time,
I wear shorts sometimes
when I'm on Gutfeld.
(Burgess laughs loudly)
We gotta get you in some
shorts or a bathing.
I'll send you something.
- Oh, my goodness.
Talk to you, Dave I
don't know if I'll do it,
but I'm welcome to try
think about it, for sure.
Okay? (laughs)
- All right, good luck, Burgess.
- Thank you, buddy.
(soft music)
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our politics playlist,
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode
playlists all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.